thank you
[Music]
so
these are the foreign objects that got
stuck into people's body during 2022.
let's go now this guy tried to say it
was [ __ ] spaghetti in the urethra hey
everything's spaghetti to somebody from
the from the butt
why would you ask did you just say right
now why would you say that Steve's best
this is about ears this is about I
thought it was like I thought it was
about how many you know like the jackass
like like Stevo he stuck the uh like a
Hot Wheel I thought it was like that
like how many people stuck things up
their butt though Jesus Christ can I
grow up in 2023 at sea level right now
guys can we just grow the [ __ ] up in
2023 is that okay with you I thought
that's what you were saying nah yeah
those penises and there's throats and
there's [ __ ] too let's go all right
so oh 36 okay Google 125. we're good
we're golden and we're and we're still
eligible for streamies
they don't know which one to pick so up
the nose fairly standard Tic Tacs level
Tic Tacs whatever [ __ ] Noob [ __ ] baby
stuff yeah you signed up you put your
email address in and you said join you
found the traffic lights a flower
someone shoved their flower up their
nose I think you would do the flower no
because you're smelling you know what
though I remember kids always stuck
things up their nose in elementary
school and I called them the crayon
eaters yeah all those kids that got
stuff stuffed sick burned the [ __ ]
they eat the crayon they do interesting
things you know what I did is I ate a
bell during Christmas time it's like one
of those stocking Bells no way yeah
because I wanted to see if I could jump
up and down in here jingling
yeah and I told my mom that she had to
take out the Merc manual and look for
like is is it gonna get metal did you
just [ __ ] it out yeah shoot it out but I
don't even know if I showed it out
because I didn't see it could you hear
it though yeah I heard it when I was
[ __ ] it out it heard it like ring
like a bell
I couldn't that was the saddest thing
yeah and then I told that story in
school and then one kid tried to call me
like like the bell bell boy or whatever
and it didn't stick it's not a good name
not a good name that was so close though
it could have stuck it could have
started your story it's already
self-deprecating and you can't be it
doesn't that's why I think it is yeah it
doesn't stick that way yeah you have to
find out about it yeah oh boy
so I'm gonna please don't make that
stick please don't please
okay so you gave Anthony thank you
fishing lore a fishing lure someone
shoved a fishing lure up their [ __ ]
nose that's crazy
cut balls a piece of a computer mouse
why wait which part probably like this
guy clicker or the squirrel oh the
clitoris remember the old ones where you
flip them over turn the thing take the
little ball out yeah yeah yeah I
remember and it's covered in dust yeah
Optical ones yeah okay we're gonna
scroll scroll scroll because who cares
about that throat
small flashlight
SIM card glue stick Bingo chip dog toy
cat toy that's what I mean what's the
point of voting these [ __ ] are
boating and then you go vote too yeah
[ __ ] it dude this is the reason why I'm
against democracy yeah [ __ ]
speaking flashlights in and they're also
voting I'm like bro well but you think
they're sticking the flashlight because
they want to see if it glows through
their throat and then it gets locked up
oh okay the benefits
also I'm a registered voter you can go
to somebody around the world who's like
looking at this fool getting like a fear
everybody tattoos like why is this
[ __ ] voting exactly none of us vote
dude I shouldn't vote you should have
vote leave it to the smart people we
won't vote we won't vote the only people
that do vote are senior citizens that
care yeah let them vote yeah 18 year
olds act like they care and then when
voting day comes they're like stoned but
senior changes only the last like three
years anyway what the [ __ ] they don't
even last a presidential that's why it
pisses me off because all the
politicians have to campaign to them
because they know they're the
responsible ones that vote so nobody the
rest of us aren't [ __ ] voting nobody
should vote dude this is the smart
people should vote like who who would
you classify for who's smart yeah but
like occupation hey man I don't want
doctors to [ __ ] vote about Finance
[ __ ] because they're not smart about it
out of all of our guests out of all of
our guests that come by who do you think
is like this person should vote
rats me honestly yeah dude uh I like him
he's great joe recipe yes
minority mindset yeah I like what's a
mortgage men of course you do of course
you do yeah other mortgage guys I mean
they have their heads on right I think
Shannon would be good well Bobby
hundreds yeah Shannon Boudreau for sure
I like Bobby he seems pretty Bobby
hundred seems fair Andy would would be a
good boss they're they're good Stevie
weebie for sure [ __ ] no wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait we're talking about
can't vote Stevie it depends on what
policy if it's if it's the pornography
how about chair smelling oh no no no
that's a that's a good platform to
understand good platform one more give
us one more vote on who can vote so up
so who votes for that a guy shoved a car
key up his penis see which which end
first oh by the way these are the most
popular was it the [ __ ] these are the
most popular things that got shoved up
oh so it's like more than one instance
type stuff this is like rankings a
wooden spoon oh my God a male Filipino
kind you can feel that one huh a nail
kind of makes uh weird sense in this
category of stuff yeah no that's the
last you know what's appropriate sicko
in here you know what's appropriate
thinking about shoving remember I texted
you thinking about it
you he told me details about Kaka this
is pretty crazy what are you talking
about so I'm not in this group okay okay
but I was showering and you guys know
how I like to like clean myself pretty
good oh telescoper until I stick it in
and then go like this and make sure you
guys all know you like to hunt for the
Red October yeah I like to clean it
stick it in Twisted very good right this
time I don't know how this happened but
I stuck my finger in further than usual
and it came here and I touched something
oh and I'm like what though that's your
G-spot I pulled my finger I felt the
turkey and it was brown I'm like oh God
you went to [ __ ] touch [ __ ] I didn't
know [ __ ] was that what did you expect
to touch I thought I don't know I did
not get this straight up [ __ ] touch
the other side of the toilet this is
like one of those TMI levels inside of
the toilet
we're trying to sell ads here we're
trying to sling ads it's like the upside
down anyway
episode of Sliders in your ass I touched
it I touched it right and then I was
like oh [ __ ] if it's like that close
might as well get it out because no one
picks their nose and they feel a
buggering I'll leave it there it's true
you go like this and you're like so did
you go back to pick your butt so I went
back in why did you guys so I went back
okay I touched my [ __ ] and then I try to
pick it and it went
that's like when they tried to rescue
the Thai kids from the cave same [ __ ]
they just ran yeah deeper and then see
taxi Joe and then this is why I'm in the
process right now I've touched something
I've never touched which is pre-laid
eggs so I had it on my fingernail and I
was like I have to I have to so I
smelled it I'm like oh my God this was
the craziest smell I've ever smelled in
my life even worse than [ __ ] and
afterwards fart smells and I had to I
had to uh when I came out of the shower
I had to tell someone because it was too
much information then I was like hey
babe I was like you said you wanted to
know everything right oh my God this guy
she goes what do you mean I was like she
was already like I was like you said you
want to be well I got to tell each other
everything I tell you something but she
also knows she doesn't like Girl Scout
stuff and then she was like does that
have anything to do with like disgusting
[ __ ] I was like yeah she was no I don't
[ __ ] know that's why I texted Joe I
gotta tell him and I was dying that's
the pre-laid eggs thing
hmm yeah you you segued so fast I was
like wait he got eggs in his ass and he
has eggs in his you know womb we usually
smell our eggs after it comes out oh
you're talking about like develop the
dog has a rotten egg stuck in his
[ __ ] and that just confirmed my
theory but I touched that egg when it's
still inside he has a rotten piece of
[ __ ] that's lodged in his intestine so
when it farts it passes through that
which he probably finally smelled
himself we all smelt it so bad
[ __ ] this nugget rolls like this
I think that's what's that that's what
happens this coffee rolls over
huh it smelled The elusive so [ __ ]
bad demonic Glade in there or something
oops
like long time Legacy nugget evil swirls
around
it runs away so you just need an enema
basically it's like it's like a barnacle
stuck on the side of a ship it's like
that Japanese soda with the Japanese the
ramen day the marble yeah how come
careful boys chat gets like your sock
updates and not this yeah I don't know
yeah I don't know if you guys want
anything about it yeah I wanna I would
love to hear about that I highly
recommend all of you guys try it and see
if you could touch your own poop are you
explicitly saying you highly recommend
all of us finger our buttholes don't do
anything no clean it but just because I
didn't really think poop was that close
to the edge I thought you said you can't
even get penetration in your butthole
because if anything gets close it
squeezes up
that's what you said right Anthony yeah
you said no part you said you said if
anything gets close you start drooling
no I've been cleaning my ass for you no
I mean it smells like you said that
right Anthony oh me
no I've been picking my [ __ ] like
that for a year in sexual Endeavors
you're so uncontrollable you'll just get
an instant divorce
you said your instant divorce you said
your dick starts drooling that's what
you said
that's what you said you said you you
said you had to wear you said you'd wear
a mouth guard for fear of cracking your
teeth from grinding too hard
there's a lot of quotes we remember okay
real quick vagina real quick vagina
we'll get stuck in the vagina a coin
what which coin a Sacagawea if you're a
lady and you get other things stuck in
your vagina that shouldn't be up in
there that's a red flag hey you know the
new quarters got a Asian lady on the
back and it's and her name is Anime Wong
nowhere anime I don't even know who that
is who's anime Wong yeah no yeah okay
get this one get this one this so this
one's a quote this is what happened this
is a quote from a doctor was holding a
pen near her vagina when the cap
dislodged and stuck inside yeah yeah
oh yeah yeah for sure
is it all sexual the stories are
probably also she probably had the cap
on and then she was like ooh trying to
be sexy put it up came out trying to be
smart is it young I just want to know
how old they are nail polish bottle oh
my that's kind of young uh flashlight
placed in vagina by patient at home but
had no intention of it becoming stuck a
whole flashlight maybe it was those
Maglite maybe the idea of making that
note like but I didn't intend for this
it didn't intense to be fair if all of
us were chicks with vaginas come on I'd
be shoving all kinds of [ __ ] in there
yeah dude well we have a butthole you
got stuff stuck in you already have an
orifice yeah dude check it out try it
out test it I'd be shoving [ __ ] Coke
Zero
[Laughter]
that's my favorite beverage
Coke Zero
what else uh rectum okay so finally we
got to the good part right rectum real
quick plastic
not part of that group a plastic toy
fish
the one that goes
the best mouth yeah dude a small bird
toy okay
a silver magnet this one
okay this is this says sent in by wife
for possible 6 160 ounce or 16 ounce
glass bottle and rectum dude 16 that's
[ __ ] big that's a lot is that a big
goal this is 16 ounces
that's a big boy [ __ ] big and it's a
glass it started with this end yeah oh
Jesus some people are very talented
piece of a lamp
up his ass what piece that doesn't say I
assume like from Christmas Story
what happened in the past before
hospitals existed people just died with
all kinds of weird stuff they're like
this man passed what a toy train in his
butthole man he could have [ __ ] this
obituary that's what this happened
I had a bird toy shoved up well it
probably comes out when you die because
you void your bowels oh that's true yeah
you know everything relaxes and things
just come out like yeah with the murder
weapon it doesn't come out in time
Rigamortis could you believe it a
crochet needle patient patience crochet
me this one gotta be good okay and this
one got me good patient State patient
states he has a big toy stuck in rectum
patient states he fell on top of it
[Applause]
has the best
she says big toys
I mean what a Mario 64 butt stop
jumps up flips
he's like dude
leaving your toys around he's like I'm
never wearing a kilt again
I'll tell you Adelia dude um okay had a
few beers and then placed a long wax
candle into his ass okay lost balance
and fell onto a couch and lost all the
candle yeah right
yeah right these stories are so rich
people [ __ ] up their ass all the time
those are oofy doofies
actors like hey you know most of the
emergency room [ __ ] is just people
sticking [ __ ] up in their bodies dude
you're gonna like this one you're like
true says girlfriend put vibrator in
rectum while he was asleep oh yeah
totally dude if you like ass play dude
just let it happen okay she stuck it in
but what if it's actually true and she
was like that gaslighting him oh yeah
yeah if that's a true story that's [ __ ]
we're not buying it though patient says
he was playing with a container of
athlete's foot spray it it accidentally
ended up
we're sensing a common theme and they're
all accidentally playing I was just like
I'm playing with this [ __ ] bottle of
happiness
and this dude is at home like this bro
he's like yeah
yeah he's like I'm playing with this
Ashley let's do a controlled experiment
and see if it's possible to accidentally
[Laughter]
I'm playing with like you know a
windshield wiper I'm a damnedest [ __ ]
thing happens my pants just dropped I I
find out shut the whole way up my
[ __ ] [ __ ]
my underwear gets down to my ankles and
I fall and I'm like you don't use these
new crutches yeah and all of a sudden
Brandon I fall onto the [ __ ]
windshield wiper I've got to be kidding
me yeah the sad thing is that none of
these people are under oath and the
person charting it just has to write
what they say I know it must feel so
stupid so good sad that's funny as [ __ ]
all right the guy was writing is like
uh-huh yeah can you imagine on your way
to the hospital you're so embarrassed
you're just trying to think of a lie
that seems real reasonable says was in
the shower and fell and the shower
stopper stucked up his ass
but the stopper though but what about
all the gerbils [ __ ] like if you get if
you show up with a hamster in your
butthole do you go oh I just crawled in
there when I was sleeping that's what
Richard Gere said right that's what
Richard Gere said is that that's not
true is it I thought it was like a it's
100 Factor had a gerbil crawl into his
[ __ ] no it's like a golf or something
it's a it's one of those like passed
around internet things and the name
always changes like how Sierra was like
yeah okay it just like changes Richard
Drew had the Caddyshack groundhog up his
ass
the Caddyshack groundhog damn all right
last one's two poker chips because of a
bet that's it we're done okay that's
good that's probably the realest one
because of a bed that is poker chips
[Music]